let's put all of the moral hazard issues
and all the fairness issues aside and
just think hard about whether this
bailout could work because frankly if it
doesn't work then it's definitely not
something that any of us should worry
about and even if it does work then I
think you should worry about the moral
hazard issues but let's say this is Bank
a shady bank a and it has and let's see
these are its assets on the left hand
side assets and these are its
liabilities a liabilities and so it has
or at least on its books the book value
of the CDOs that it has is five billion
dollars and what the government is
saying is that you know like right now
Bank B has lent Bank a this loan right
bank B has given them eight billion
dollars maybe has to be paid back next
month and and the big fear is is that
Bank B is going to get scared and then
when this loan is doing it I'm in a in a
month's time that Bank B won't give them
a new loan or renew the loan that
they're just going to want to take the
money back because they're kind of
afraid of keeping money with these guys
when you don't know what these CDOs are
worth and that's that's a legitimate
fear right because if these CDOs really
are worth five billion dollars then you
really do have four billion dollars of
equity here right total assets are
twelve billion minus eight billion of
liabilities means you have four billion
of equity fair enough but what happens
if these CEOs are only worth 1 billion
dollars and this is worth 1 billion and
these are worth seven billion then you
only have 8 billion in assets and 8
billion in liabilities and there's no
equity or even worse what if this is if
these CDOs are worth zero then you have
negative equity then if these guys were
to go bankrupt if they were to do if
they were to be the next Lehman Brothers
then all all this this lender lender B
would get if they went bankrupt are
these CDOs worth zero and the 7 billion
of assets so for every eight dollars
they lent to Bank a they'll only get $7
so what the government is saying is okay
to keep Bank B from pulling their money
out of Bank a let's buy out these CDOs
at essentially a price that keeps this
Bank solvent so you know even if they
really are worth zero we're
the the Fed or the Treasury the
Treasury's the one that's doing it the
Treasury is not gonna pay zero because
if they paid zero this guy would go
bankrupt there'd be another Lehman
Brothers so the Treasury wants to
essentially maybe pay five billion for
it so that you know you've take five
billion out of take five billion by
these CEOs for five billion and all of a
sudden this doesn't become CDOs of five
billion this becomes cash and their
argument is is if you were do this no
matter how unfair it might be because
this is essentially a cheque of five
billion dollars if you assume the CDO is
worthless this is essentially a cheque
that's being written to the equity
holders and the unsecured debt holders
of this of this Bank but let's let's
assume that let's put all of that aside
and let's assume that this works that
this now now Bank B will say oh boy you
know that I don't have to worry about
those CDOs anymore those CEOs have been
turned into cash this company definitely
has positive positive Book value and
therefore I will continue to lend to
this company but it isn't that simple
because right behind these CDOs there
are other assets on this book on most
banks books so these were the subprime
CDOs the stinkiest of the stinky then
you have other things that are a little
bit less risky there are alt a CDOs
these are loans that were given to
people who aren't necessarily subprime
these are people who had decent credit
scores but they still put no money down
and they still were able to essentially
fabricate their income on their loan
application so these are the altai loans
and then of above that and these might
be all taste CDO so they've been sliced
and diced so some tranches are more
risky some tranches or less risky above
that you might have I don't know you
might have a commercial real estate CDOs
so I'll call that commercial real estate
CDOs and then above that you might have
commercial loans you know just a regular
companies commercial loans or even
better these could be loans to private
equity actually that's even better let's
put some private equity loans in there
cuz I wanted to show you that this isn't
the only stinky thing on the balance
sheet these CDOs that this is just the
stinkiest of them all a good way to
think about it is if you have a dead
skunk in your house
you won't notice that the milk is going
bad right and that is the situation
these CDOs they seem really bad now but
you know what six months ago or even a
year ago six months ago these CDOs
looked a lot like these subprime studios
look a lot like these altes CEOs are
starting to look and the way these off a
CDOs looked six months ago is how a lot
of these commercial real estate CDOs are
starting to look right now so this is
just the tip of the iceberg these CDOs
so you have an issue here the government
goes in it spent seven hundred billion
dollars it buys these assets that are of
questionable value and it's claiming to
us that the problem will be solved but
Bank B isn't an idiot Bank B is an idiot
they were probably more prudent than
bank a right they didn't buy the
subprime they didn't buy these subprime
assets subprime CDOs but I wouldn't be
surprised if Bank B probably has some of
these less stinky things on their
balance sheet alt a I mean they
definitely have something stinky which
is called a loan to be sorry a loan to a
right that's one of their assets and
then they have you know they might have
loans to private equity private equity
loans then they might have some
commercial real estate CDOs they might
have CDOs that are backed by credit card
debt the bottom line is is that this
Bank can look into its own assets and it
can see that the fundamental value
behind these assets are deteriorating
anyone who talks to anyone in the real
economy right now than those that the
economy is slowing that consumers can't
spend any more money if in fact in fact
last year consumers had negative savings
which means that they had to borrow
money to fuel their consumption and the
only way that you can have consumption
growth in that type of an environment is
if either salaries increase which isn't
happening or people are able to borrow
more money and we already know that
credit is getting tightened so if you're
a bank B will will this will the
government buying out this asset
irregardless of how fair it is will that
make you confident in loaning to Bank a
well no because you see in your own
balance sheet that these things are
deteriorating and
frankly you have loans to other people
to write you have loans loans to you
know I'll say that's a loan to bank see
that's a loan to bank II that's a loan
to I don't know some sovereign wealth
fund and then you have your equity here
right so you have you have a double
conundrum right you have all of these
guys these loans might come due so
you're gonna need some cash for that in
the future and you see the trend you're
not an idiot you weren't as risk-taking
is this guy and you see that this that
this wasn't the only stinky thing out
there that there are other asset classes
there are other types of CDOs and just
loans in general that are starting to
deteriorate that's starting to
deteriorate that's starting to
deteriorate that's starting to
deteriorate so maybe this credit crunch
isn't just because of these CDOs maybe
it's because this banker is actually
being prudent
maybe this banker is actually saying you
know what I need to be careful I see the
left-hand side of my balance sheet
deteriorating I need to pull this money
just in case just really in the best
interest of my equity holders right or
my shareholders or even in my bond
holders so even on this first cut even
if even if there wasn't all of this
controversy and even if George Bush
didn't go up and you know do a
prime-time speech telling us that we're
about to reach financial Armageddon if I
was a prudent banker I would still be
wary of loaning to bank a even if the
government were able to pull this buyout
now on top of that you know I work in
the financial industry bankers were
prudent you know they see reality they
see things are deteriorating so they
want to be cautious but frankly when
bush and Paulson and Bernanke go up on
TV and say tell the world that you have
to pass this bill and if not we're
essentially on you know they use words
like precipice these are the real
precipice and they you know they use
financial Armageddon I don't know if
that was that's either their words or
some of the other words that that I've
heard out there for financial Armageddon
and you know days away
days away from the precipice so my
question is to you regardless of whether
the government buys this out is this
type of language going to instill any
heipo sense of confidence in Bank B if
I'm the chairman or I'm the CEO of Bank
B I'm like you know what I thought
things were bad and that's why I was
trying to you know instead of charge two
percent for a loan I was gonna charge
six percent for a loan
but now the president estates the
Treasury secretary and the chairman of
the Federal Reserve have frankly used
language that no elected or unelected
official has ever used before days away
from financial Armageddon we're on the
precipice hell I'm definitely not gonna
lend my now I don't care even if they do
even if they do buy asset and then I'm
gonna throw another monkey wrench into
the picture the the the plan calls out
the plan calls for a reverse mortgage a
sorry a reverse auction where though
essentially the Fed says hey everybody I
have a billion dollars who wants to sell
me their mortgages for the lowest price
well guess what the people who are
willing to sell their mortgages for
their CEOs for the lowest price are
probably the most desperate out there
and if anyone participates in those
auctions and sells at a discount those
are the people that are gonna be on my
red flag list those are the banks that
I'm going to be the least likely to lend
to because I knew that they were
desperate that they were just covering
up their balance sheet as long as they
could they were waiting for the
government bailout and if they're
willing to take the government bailout
those are the very banks that I don't
want to lend to anyway I'll leave you
there but I just want to give you the
point that you know everyone that George
Bush and the rest of his gang is trying
to scare the world and saying oh you
know we are trying to save the economy
they don't mention the fact that even
with their bailout regardless of how
unfair it is we're probably going to end
up in the same situation and frankly it
might even make the situation worse and
that's that's something I really want to
hit home with people it's like it's like
when they started banning short selling
in a small number of stocks right when
they said oh you can't but you can't
short banks a B and C immediately that
made everyone's ears go up and say oh
the government knows something that we
don't know I'm not gonna deal with banks
a B and C because those are probably the
stinkiest of them all anyway see in the
next video